بعد انظمه صواريخ بعيده المدى ومدرعات
وانظمه دفاع جوي ارضي دبابات تشارجر اثنين
البريطانيه الصنع في طريقها الى القوات
الاكرانيه في احدث دعم عسكري لكيف للتصدي
للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه المستمره هذا
ما اعلنه رئيس الوزراء البريطانيك واكده
وزير الدفاع للنواب
عن اهم حزمه من القوه القتاليه حتى الان
لتسريع النجاح الاوكراني تشمل سربا من
دبابات تشالنجر اثنين بمركبات الاسترداد
واصلاح المدرعات وسوف نتبرع بسلاح
المدفعين مضره لاوكرانيا مجهز بثمن بنادق
عاليه الدقه واسلحه المدفعيه اخرى في
مراحل مختلفه من الجاهليه
هذه الحزمه العسكريه الجديده من بريطانيا
الى اوكرانيا حظيت بتاييد النواسع من
مختلف الاحزاب السياسيه للوقوف في وجه
الرئيس بوتن الذي اخطا في تقدير حملته
العسكريه ولوقوف الدول الغربيه في صف واحد
بجانب الرئيس الاوكراني لحمايه اراضي
بلاده كما تقول لندن تعمل كيف ان يمهد
القرار البريطاني ارسال الحلفاء اسلحه
ومعدات عسكريه ثقيله متطوره للقوات
الاوكرانيه كانت قبل اشهر فقط من المحرمات
لتفادي تصعيدي روسيا الحرب
اوكرانيا اقنعت حلفائها البريطانيين
والفرنسيين والبولنديين تدريجيا لارسال
اسلحه النوعيه تحدث فارقا على ارض
الاقتتال ما سيزيد الضغط على برلين لتسليم
الدبابات قتاليه حديثه من نوع لابرد اثنين
الى استخدام دباباتها يجب ان تكون في
اوكرانيا للقتال على الارض وينطبق الشيء
نفسه على كل دوله لا تزال تمتلك اسلحه في
المخازن ولا تمنحها لاوكرانيا واحد اكبر
التهديدات للامن في العالم هو روسيا
والبلد الوحيد القادر على ايقاف روسيا هو
اوكرانيا
بريطانيا التي تعتبر ثانيه اكبر المانحين
لاوكرانيا بعد الولايات المتحده سيحث رئيس
وزراءها ريش سوناك الشركاء الغربيين على
التسريع الدعم لاوكرانيا مع اقتراب مرور
عام على الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وروسيا
في موقف ضعيف في ساحه المعركه بسبب مشاكل
الامداد وتدهور روحي معنويه جنودها
فذروا العربيه لندن